hello oh sorry sorry now you're just
being naughty I won't say anything I
won't say anything to her right now
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to gmod with five nights at
Freddy's because Wade has been basically
demanding that I play it because
apparently is amazing really into the
microphone was very good how could I not
so I'm here with Bob and Wade say hi
guys oh my god okay so Wade you've
played this before so you're gonna guide
us through this experience it's very
scary cuz it's five nights at freddy's
and it's pretty well emulating the game
right there's a phone okay okay well
that was long and interesting and really
really quiet for some reason yeah don't
run towards me with your character model
Wade I'm scared okay so we're gonna
wander around because that's what the
guy said to do right there's the
steroids everyone leave for a few
seconds I need to inject this all up
straight up my [ __ ] hey I got the
door open the door Wade I got I got some
electrons I'm gonna try and bribe
Freddie to be cool yeah alright go sell
the electronics to Freddy okay hello
okay so everybody was talking about this
map because it is a recreation but it
actually allows you to play around in
the thing so that's cool so we can see
these guys right here
they don't seem that bad Freddy looks
creepy this Freddy take take take that
oh okay why is the power off and I need
to get good looks at these guys after
you get a good look you
definitely come into this employees only
room why where I'm looking at I'm
looking very detailed Lili you can see
even more details in here oh really
I'll go right in sounds like a plan
why aren't you coming in wait yes that's
what it was geez sorry
Wow my bad okay let's get to spook on oh
I thought Bonnie had left I was like Oh
scares aah oh my god I just flipped my
headphones off of my head Oh Wade what
are you still Foxy's here yeah oh good I
thought you said he wasn't here the
curtains were open I didn't say that
who's Bob you say Oh Bobby I'm blade
this oh jeez yep I haven't played this
goddamn those I just almost farted out
my lungs for you when you see my face
scan for that you're gonna be like what
the hell what was he thinking was gonna
happen
any react like he was cool water's
moving oh do I know turn my back to him
what do I do
go say hi okay give him a hug hello mark
don't do it don't you see that the
camera we see your flashlight can you
see me you need to look close you can
see me can you see me like pulled me in
all right then okay okay fine yeah so
Freddie's got to wait yeah this is this
is kind of actually happening that close
the doors
okay oh my god okay Jesus waited and
tell me this game was like this no like
this
played in a while God changed it I don't
know how much power we have and are the
doors just gonna do what they do in the
actual game right no I'm turning up my
game audio just so that like people at
home don't think we're giant pansies
about the skiers okay all right so wait
what do we do what is the objective oh
yeah where's that oh that right outside
the door
all right let me I'm gonna go out there
no no okay that's a bad idea
he's to the right okay so we just keep
the doors closed forever is what we do
right use the cameras and stuff you know
all the lights weren't off it'd be a lot
easier yeah wait I'll turn my I'll go
you want me to scout hey it's clear in
here now okay what do we do now
chicas still on the stage Bonnie's on
the stage so that's pretty good I guess
honey went back to the stage I think I
need a crowbar Bob cuz chicas gone
oh no don't let it back in Wow yeah okay
yeah that's probably for the best I mean
one for all and you're for us and go to
hell Wade that goes right pretty sure
that's how it goes for us Wade don't go
out there
wait what oh yeah she goes in the
bathroom it's right there careful wait
don't go in there chicas in the bathroom
okay
Oh guys who Bonnie's on the stage no no
Wade Wade Oh
wait so go restart the power wait oh you
got to keep power okay coast is clear
wait Bob since you have a key Oh Foxy's
happy I'll go open the door I'll listen
or I'll scout it out oh well you gotta
get that's the key right
mark mark will you do the power the
power come here oh he's gone whoa okay
uh-huh
I'm doing the power okay you're down
there yeah okay so the hot I'm coming
I'm coming
oh it's it on Wayne I think so are we
safe down here
no oh here why not they will kill you oh
good
good to know I just saw a head mark and
I'll scout I'll clear the way Oh
someone's at our door we should go down
there
he's right here Oh God Oh both doors are
closed off we're stuck here for a little
bit [ __ ] christ
oh that is quit that's okay clear
hallways clear we need to go back door
door door okay oh god I think we get
look can't we leave the door open or is
it only when they get there ah no but
the power is gonna go out it looks like
you're holding your hands in your mouth
wait you're holding your cheeks apart
hey don't judge it till you try it
I'd rather not hold my cheeks apart
ready still there Oh God you didn't tell
me wait it was like this this is so much
worse than it was okay
why chica chica changed chicas in the
right hallway is there a timer like are
we ever gonna win I don't know those you
just changed it forever
okay so on open this door
Freddy's gone okay y-you idiot I didn't
see you in the hallway okay well don't
go out there bub this this hallway is
clear okay so where it is on the stage
and so it's bonny butt cheek is still
over in the hallway okay so I don't know
I gave you like 30 seconds heads up
should we let them in panels okay okay
so crowbar yeah the thing I have a
crowbar
Bob open the Kokiri break this vent is
this a trap mark and Bob need to go in
there
this traffic ma forward Bob and you only
look to the other great what uh that's
horrifying
what is it and wait come out come out
Lucy well I forget how they are watching
the cameras and [ __ ] whoa
golden Freddy that's awesome
what does he do anything I don't he
didn't before but like I said they've
changed everything since I played guys
chicas in the kitchen and Freddy's not
on the stage okay all right then
where's Freddy I've know you're in the
bathroom all right you you keep watching
the cameras Bob I'll watch the doors
this is actually stressful I'm surprised
it's so much worse than the actual game
it's cuz it just keeps happening and it
never ends okay at least when I lose at
the real five nights at freddys it's
just over yeah that's true
okay so honey how do you tell when
Foxy's coming I don't know what he
starts to creep out now smile and stuff
yeah he looks like your pretty head
thank you you're the best okay mark what
oh where are you at oh okay we're good
we're good we're good we're good where
was he where was he he was to the right
in the oh I see I see you see I got you
I got you
it's right there what was that sound
there's pretty sit sound the Ferdie
makes okay Wade is does it go to 6:00
a.m. does it end it didn't use to it
might now I don't know okay I'm gonna go
ahead and say that it probably won't
work so is there any other secret that
we should find before we
fun to sit in the room and watch foxy
come visit okay how do we do that air in
the room and don't watch him hi foxy
highfive slick him on the camera so
that's are you there I'm watching foxy
don't do that god oh go away right
Freddy whoa
hey I hear some shuddering oh they're
both in here I died
why okay I'm going to the bathroom I'm
gonna see if there's anything in there
okay okay he's open a bowl yeah all this
pro pitiable I don't think they go in
the stall though I doubt it taking a
dump like Disney World they just get out
of their suit for a little bit Oh what
okay Freddy's gone thank god these are
all locked there we go you are gone
right okay good okay yeah I know how to
play five nights at Freddy's coming okay
all right okay this coming whoa they're
both down that hallway Freddy and chica
and [ __ ] okay oh man okay so I think
we've done everything we could right
yeah it's pretty much it a thing okay so
if there's more please let us know in
the comments below because we want to
know more this is way better than I
thought
Wade has been telling me for like a week
I need to play this but I'm like no no I
played the real one I beat it I'm like
that could be done I don't think that's
gonna work
I'm gonna take him out guys you got
door door Bob Bob I'm so sorry Bob I'm
so sorry
necessity go to golden Freddy go in
there Oh Freddy okay he's gone she is
gone not gone he's gone
Oh God here I'll open the door he's gone
oh you're welcome you're welcome you're
well
Freddy's still there though that's cool
okay so just uh yeah just leave this
comment if there's anything else we
should find out about and thank you
everybody for joining me Bob and Wade
and for your chamber I guess thank me
for joining you know I will
[Music]
[Music]
a bunch is trading together
[Music]